police a saisi hier soir à Paris un
stock de mortier d'artifice plusieurs
personnes d'ailleurs ont été interpellés
c'est un stock qui faisait pas loin de
400 kg pourquoi ont-ils attaqué des
médiathèques des écoles pour qu'ont
pas des excuses toujours dans le
comportement de la police un million
636240 euros précisément c'est le
montant définitif de la cagnotte au
profit de la famille du policier mis en
examen si elle doit se réformer monsieur
Durand et je sais que je parle à la
républicain et doit aussi être d'éviter
être un bouc émissaire pour se poser les
bonnes questions cette cagnotte était
indigne indigne sur le fond et puis un
jean sur les messages qui étaient
véhiculés on est ici sur des sphères qui
relèvent de l'ultra droite ou de
l'extrême droite c'est une provocation
totalement
inopportune mais elle révèle beaucoup de
choses elle révèle un élan de solidarité
très fort d'une majorité silencieuse de
Français vis-à-vis de leur policiers au
tribunal de Lyon ou hier une salle
d'audience a dû être évacuée alors que
25 et métiers étaient jugés en
comparution immédiate car des militants
d'ultra gauche sont entrés dans le
tribunal les 1,6 millions montrent qu'au
final les Français soutiennent la police
contrairement à ce que l'on entend à
longueur de discours d'extrême gauche
qui nous chante tout le monde déteste la
police
[Applaudissements]
moi je suis un peu étonné quand même
qu'on soit si choqué par les 1 million
six destinés à la famille d'un policier
quand on sait que les émeutes vont nous
coûter un milliard un milliard prix dans
la poche des gens qui travaillent un
milliard de dégâts c'est n'importe quoi
aujourd'hui c'est pas le chiffre
aujourd'hui qui est validé et ça n'est
pas le chiffre que nous avons nous
sommes en train de remonter les chiffres
il a combien le chiffre validé pour
l'instant à date on est on sera
certainement sur quelques centaines de
millions possiblement mais je rappelle
quand même une évidence qui doit payer
c'est d'abord les assureurs qui vont
payer les commerces sont assurés des
assurances doivent jouer et elles
joueront je les remercie d'ailleurs
d'avoir accepté de simplifier les
procédures d'allonger le délai de dépôt
de plainte je pense aussi à des parents
qui pourraient faire un certain nombre
de choses vis-à-vis de leurs enfants en
particulier assuré l'autorité parentale
et qui ne le font pas
366 personnes ont été incarcérées pour
ces violences et dégradations un tiers
des personnes interpellées était des
mineurs
et cette proportion était même de 54% la
nuit de dimanche à lundi où il y a une
vidéo qui m'a plu c'est celle du père
qui va récupérer son gamin par le
callback et qui lui diront à la maison
parce qu'à 11 ans traîne pas dans les
rues tout ça pour rien absolument pour
rien c'est détruire pour détruire abîmer
le pays pour abîmer le pays c'est
totalement un qualifiable inexcusable
moi je pense qu'il faut leur pourrir
leurs vacances je pense que tous ces
casseurs tous ces incendiaires il faut
que on les mette hors d'état de nuire il
faut les sanctionner je pense qu'il faut
des centres éducatifs fermés pour les
mineurs on a une supprimer la majorité
l'excuse de minorité parce que bien
souvent cette excuse de minorité est
utilisée par les trafiquants drogue pour
exposer des mineurs sachant qu'il ne
risque rien si là il faut aussi
s'interroger sur le fait que ces jeunes
gens ne soient pas en mesure de se
mettre à la place de l'autre là on est
quand même dans une société qui est tout
de même extrêmement
en grande difficulté quand vous êtes
dans l'incapacité de vous mettre à la
place de l'autre donc vous pouvez le
détruire j'ai en 2005 du jour au
lendemain les émeutes se sont arrêtés
après trois semaines parce qu'il y a eu
un coup de sifflet on arrête la récré
c'est la fin de la récréation le shit
est là on vend et du jour au lendemain
et on est certainement dans un sur une
page beaucoup plus courte dans ce même
phénomène ainsi les parents seront mis
face à leur responsabilité avec des
amendes des stages de responsabilisation
parentale pour je le précise ceux qui ne
répondraient pas aux convocations dans
les procédures mettant en cause leur
enfant l'événement fait grand bruit
relayer sur les réseaux sociaux la salle
de spectacle La Flèche d'Or annonce ce
soir un concert de soutien aux collectif
des familles de victimes et jeunes
interpellaient lors des émeutes liés à
la mort de Naël vous êtes parents d'un
enfant mineur vous n'avez pas à laisser
sortir votre enfant dans la rue encore
moins dans un contexte des motures Ben
et donc il est nécessaire là où il y a
défaillance qu'il y ait des sanctions
réparations c'est une honte de faire un
concert comme ça et en plus il demande
d'être payé en liquide pour l'entrée
double comptabilité allez arrêtons les
conneries